" - Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ma question est simple:
que comptez-vous faire
maintenant
pour éradiquer l’islam
politique et rétablir l’autorité
et la fermeté
dans notre patrie ?
- Que se passe-t-il chez Engie
l’un de nos fleurons industriels français?
- Quelle est la position de notre pays
dans cette négociation essentielle
pour l’avenir
de la pêche française? "
Obtenir les Questions
au Gouvernement sur l’antenne
cette exclusivité,
c’était un long combat
que tous les Présidents de LCP
ont essayé de gagner.
Les Questions au Gouvernement
c’est le rendez-vous hebdomadaire
où on se fait connaître
en posant une question.
" Ma question est très simple:
êtes-vous favorable à une majoration
de la cotisation de solidarité
pour les très hauts revenus? "
C’est aussi un rendez-vous
qui est un peu théâtral.
" - L’élégance de votre question
n’a d’égale
que l’inexactitude des propos
que vous y tenez.
- Madame le Ministre,
l’euphémisation de votre réponse
ne cache pas la brutalité
de votre méthode.
Les avocats savent lire,
ils ont très bien compris."
Mais, derrière, il y a toujours
de vrais débats politiques.
" Le pouvoir d’achat s’est-il amélioré?
Non.
La compétitivité a-t-elle explosé?
Le chômage a-t-il chuté?
Non. "
Il y avait quand
même un paradoxe
c’est que la chaîne qui est dédiée
à l’actualité parlementaire
se voyait privée
du programme
qui était le plus emblématique
du travail parlementaire.
" L’ordre du jour appelle
les Questions au Gouvernement. "
Il y avait une crainte
chez les députés
que, si on changeait de la 3 à LCP,
il y ait beaucoup de gens
qui cessent de regarder
les Questions au Gouvernement.
Or France 3
c’était leur intérêt aussi
puisque les Questions au Gouvernement,
c’était une obligation pour eux
qui tombait un peu
comme un pavé
au milieu de leur
programme de l’après-midi.
" Bonjour à tous
et bienvenue
dans Questions d'Actualité.
2h30 de direct consacré
à l'actualité politique et parlementaire.
À 15h, vous vivrez en direct
les Questions au Gouvernement. "
L’intérêt de cette exclusivité,
ce n’est pas uniquement de dire:
on est les seuls à l’avoir.
C’est avoir 2 caméras
dans l’hémicycle
en plus des caméras
de l’Assemblée.
" Nous serons en duplex
de la salle des 4 colonnes
avec Stéphanie Depierre
et Clément Méric.
Et puis nous serons au plus
près des députés dans l’hémicycle
et ce sera Rahabi Ka que
nous allons retrouver dans un instant. "
Les Questions au Gouvernement
pour LCP
c’est un gros bloc d’audience
et c’est aussi une porte d’entrée
pour démontrer tout ce qui est fait autour
et après de pouvoir renvoyer
sur les autres programmes de la chaîne.
C’est pour ça que c’était déterminant
pour LCP d’obtenir cette liberté éditoriale
cette exclusivité sur
les Questions au Gouvernement.